what up space fam Golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story and wow this chapter is
Big we got not only the fate of our
characters revealed after the whole
Cliffhanger of what happened to Luffy
and jewelry Bonnie last time but we also
get the Vega Punk reveal after so many
years and of course there's very
interesting information about Kobe the
sword organization working for the
Marines and much more it's definitely
not one you want to miss so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
these one piece reviews I want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the parking within and smash that like
button to let me know very simple be a
smashing pirate king rather than passing
Orochi and YouTube will reward you with
funky fireworks around your YouTube
thumb it definitely worked on my phone
but then again it didn't work on my
MacBook so I'm not sure if you guys will
get the fireworks but you know you'll
get symbolic fireworks that signify how
happy you're making me if you do it make
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece reviews and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all this chapter chapter
1061 is called Egghead the island of the
future a pretty hype title and as you
probably guessed right now a reference
to vegapunk so we return to the straw
hats Luffy's saved jewelry Bonnie in a
way but they're not out of danger yet
now the two of them and Chopra are
hurtling through the air we find out
that there's something below and it
takes the form of a giant shark coming
up to swallow the ship from beneath the
water the straw hats avoid getting their
ship eaten but a giant shark looking
thing has surfaced even though it's too
big to be a shark and it's made of metal
meanwhile as the ship is bracing for a
rough Landing jinbei sees that Luffy
Chopper and Bonnie fell in the water so
he goes in after them leaving Frankie to
take the help I'm glad we get a
situation like this because it really
outlines how important jimbei is for the
crew especially since Luffy is a devil
fruit user vulnerable to the ocean
thanks to jinbei he doesn't have to
worry about something like this being
the end of him even though for pirates
this could be a very very dangerous
situation anyways back to metal Jaws the
metal shark shoots at her ship up and
the remaining crew on it and causes them
to capsize they also fall into the water
and someone better save our devil fruit
using Robin quick so we have another one
of these situations where it looks like
the crew is going to be split up which
kind of makes sense since they are an OP
yonko crew now so this Nerfs them a bit
back to jinbei jimbei tries to go up but
because of a tremendous current and
shark cannons jinbei decides to dive
again escaping from the explosion the
shark turns to the ship and the other
crew members before a cool looking Mecha
Robot shows up and punches the shark not
only devil fruit users are struggling
here since the current is so strong it's
preventing anyone from getting back up
to the surface at the moment as all this
craziness is going on we jump to a
nearby Island the G14 Naval Base Navy HQ
Captain tashigi is there and she's
helping The Giant children with their
medicine clearly the kids like her a lot
with some even saying he's only drinking
the medicine because she told them to
another one comments that they've shrunk
quite a bit to which toshigi agrees
saying the girl is hardly recognizable
then G14 Commander vice admiral Dahl
breaks in to talk about our boy helmeppo
she wants toshigi to do something about
him but the Shiki says she can't since
his best friend's life is on the line
she says she's worried too since he's
their junior as a marine after all Navy
HQ Lieutenant Commander and member of
sword helmepo and navy HQ commander and
member of Sword Peabody are begging for
Navy HQ rear Admiral and member of Sword
Prince Grouse and his forces to help
rescue Kobe from Pirate Island where
Blackbeard is and it must be noted how
mepo is crying hard however it's pointed
out that Pirate Island as I mentioned is
yonko Blackbeard's Turf and that they'll
get sworn by Pirates if they stick their
nose into that beehive to be fair though
even if they don't like Kobe personally
this does not look good for the Marines
having one of their own kidnapped let
alone a hero of theirs so the Marines
should definitely make his return a
priority if at all possible for Public
Image if not for Kobe him self how mepo
says that Egghead is close so can't they
deploy a seraphim as alluded to in the
title Egghead is vegapunk's Island which
is near so we're maybe looking at a
helmeppo Luffy Alliance here to help
save Kobe from Blackbeard not sure but
it should be interesting to see where
this goes nonetheless I really don't
think it's a coincidence though that
these two are so close together right
now for now though the answer how mepo
gets is that they need to calm down for
a minute Prince comments on how they
can't even get a hold of Drake either
they're no position to act right now
again as if reminding us that another
one of Kobe's friends is nearby we jump
to Luffy's group Next Luffy is hilarious
in the sense that he can't even remember
who Bonnie is even though she's also a
member of the worst generation but at
least they appear to be safe now they're
on dry land although they're not dry
themselves we see Bonnie and she's
taking her adult form again as she's
trying to dry her clothes even though
Sanji would be losing his mind here
Luffy completely ignores the fact that
she's shirtless she says to Luffy their
enemies but also thanks him for saving
her bacon and Luffy hilariously calm
comments don't sweat it Boogie Luffy is
messing around having a good time and
commenting on how it's so cold and
Bonnie can't help but remark Are you
seriously an emperor and that's what I
love about this part of the story before
the yako seemed aloof serious and cool
but now that our protagonist is ayanko
we see how even though other people may
see him that way who haven't met him
he's still the same very human character
we've come to know so well Yanko or not
and I'm sure Goldie Roger was a similar
story for those who knew him the best
Bonnie also asks Luffy about his hair
and how it's not white like in his
wanted poster she says they made quite a
stir about it in the newspapers which
makes me wonder if word about the sun
god returning and joy boy returning has
started to spread Luffy comments that's
just how he looks when he's totally free
interesting choice of words there
definitely not huge mind-blowing
dialogue right here but very interesting
nonetheless when Bonnie asks about Luffy
not being worried about the rest of his
crew Luffy just laughs saying they'll
figure it out he has faith in them after
all you know sora's not gonna let
anything go down meanwhile Bonnie still
can't believe that Luffy got the Knight
of the sea jinbei with him as well
jimbei asks what happened to her ship
and crew only to be told that she came
alone the metal shark that almost
gobbled up the straw hat ship also
gobbled up her ship and then she says
she's starving something she's got in
common with Luffy finally Bonnie lets
them know where they are she says this
is a government Island they're on
Egghead the island that's set to be 500
years in the future as a Sci-Fi fan AKA
a huge fan of Science Fiction I'm so
excited to see how creative Oda will get
here this seems to be a great
opportunity for Oda to really Flex his
creative muscles by being able to show
us how 500 years into the future would
look Bonnie adds Vega Punk's research
lab is based here and reveals that Vega
punks the reason she's here they've got
business not surprising when you
remember Bonnie cry over Kuma during the
reverie we return to the rest of the
crew and the ship the mecca robot has
lifted them up Frankie obviously loves
the Mecca and so do I honestly it's it's
awesome then a figure steps out of the
robot they are vexed at the fact that
the shark keeps trying to swallow ships
saying maybe overriding Primal desires
is simply impossible clearly this is a
mad scientist who can't even stop
thinking about their work as they're
introducing themselves to strangers
Frankie thanks the figure for saving
them the figure removes their goggles
while saying they ordered the mecca
shark to scout report and fire but if it
keeps trying to eat chips there won't be
anything to salvage I must have bungled
the programming end quote we finally see
the full body and this mad scientist is
revealed to be a beautiful woman she
says forgive me but did you say I just
saved you oh you naive Pirates I work
for the government despite my mediocrity
they like to call me their scientific
genius you can call me Dr vegapunk and
there you have it the first reveal of
vegapunk after hundreds and hundreds of
chapters Vega Punk has been built up so
much this is truly a big moment in one
history and I can't wait to see how this
Arc goes obviously we gotta spend some
time on this futuristic Island and
learning more about vegapunk but it's
clear that helmeppo is so close and that
Luffy would want to save Kobe too so I
can't wait to see where exactly we go
from here definitely glad that they
introduced yet another waifu into the
story but who would have thought it
would be vegapunk obviously most of us
thought it would be emu summer but back
to vegapunk I love her character so far
and even how she clearly appears to be
modest even as she's considered the
greatest scientist ever place your bets
on how old the scientist actually is
since with science I assume much older
than she looks we even saw translation
note that says old-timer speech so this
definitely has me intrigued but that is
it for this one we'll definitely be
talking a lot more about this and Vega
punk in future videos so make sure
you're subscribed smash that like button
if you enjoyed this review I want to
keep them coming be a smashing pirate
king rather than passing Orochi and
YouTube will reward you with funky
fireworks around your YouTube thumb one
more time make sure to subscribe
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to throw all notifications so you don't
miss future one piece reviews and
updates and while you wait for the next
shout out to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on Shanks mihawk
all Admirals most recently all God
fruits the most interesting category of
devil fruits and much more link to that
is in the description on screen right
now and until next time see you Space
Cowboys